Earl Thomas had a tough week we talked
about him last week remember
I thought you say the tough week I think
you're the best week ever he well he
suffered a season-ending ankle slashed
leg injury broke his leg look no tendons
no not he's gonna be fine
time for the Super Bowl Wow or free
agency whichever comes for free agency
the Seahawks safety was carted off the
field of the Seahawks game in Arizona
last week and famously as he was getting
carted to the locker room flipped off
the Seahawks idling the entire Seahawks
team that's trainers
that's coaches that's players that's
that's like side judges got the finger
that is the best way you can get carted
off like you know how that people used
to do like the thumbs up when they were
going off the field like to salute the
fans know they were okay this should be
the new one but like if you're in like a
back brace and they're carrying you off
like you flipped the sideline useful
flip the bird to your own team that's
baller I don't think it was to his
teammates or to anyone else that it was
to the entire tip Pete Carroll the the
head coach and generally the
organization that hasn't given him the
long term contract you know that that he
wanted that's what you think I think he
just thought like this is best case
scenario like if I don't practice all
season playing the games kick ass and
then if I get hurt at all they're all
getting the finger even the coach Pete
Carroll wasn't mad Pete Carroll was like
cut him some slack yeah junior Smith
Cleveland Cavalier was upset this week
by a report that the NBA will find him
if he does not cover up his supreme logo
tattoo supreme some sort of clothing
store it's a brain I don't the store or
a brand I see people with bags it looks
like it looks like a bumper sticker that
people put on clothes sometimes I don't
understand it I'm old I don't like it do
you think that's cool I mean it's it's a
fashion sort of street where you'll see
people lined up for hours we thought we
saw people in Soho when we were in
London Erica and I at like 10:00 in the
morning lined up for the supreme there
and
what's going on I'm too old yeah I don't
understand that the clothes don't look
good like it just seems like you're
wearing the label you could just get
like a sticker and put it on a regular
shirt and everyone be cool with that
Junior Smith got it tattooed down in his
calf like up his leg much money must he
have made for that no I there's no way
supreme paid him for that I bet he did
it thinking laughs yes yeah do you think
he restarted the company was like what
if I get supreme I think they probably
reached out to a bunch of athletes
offering I don't know $200,000 or
something that if you get supreme
tattooed on you and he was the only one
that took them no way no way if LeBron
did one to do it they bag will pay you
everything but there is no they don't
need that that's not gonna help them
it's not like oh one of the worst
players on the Cavs the guy who blew
Game one of the finals we want that guy
to be our spokesperson put a tattoo on
his leg no way no way but I think he's
gonna have to cover it up other players
have had to cover tattoos with logos on
them Greg this reminds me again of
another story last week Arby's all right
Arby's Restaurant chain had a promo
giveaway where they a hundred people got
free tattoos I believe somewhere in
California a tattoo shop they could go
on and get these different Arby's
tattoos on their body and the reward was
nothing you got a free tattoo is on your
body for life but you do not get a free
Arby's sandwich you don't get pretty
curly fries you don't get a free RC Cola
you get nothing because years ago
Domino's Pizza did a thing worth in
Russia what if you got a tattoo of
Domino's on your body free Domino's for
life and so many Russians did it that
they had to cancel it so all these
people had the Domino's tattoos and
couldn't get free pizza and lost their
minds now this was just strictly like if
you wanted an Arby's tattoo on your body
you could get it which is the dumbest
thing anyone could ever do Greg if you
were gonna get a corporate a corporation
logo on your body what would you get hmm
I'm in a little inspired by Isaiah koel
do you remember this story from a few
weeks ago where he pretended to wipe his
ass
after a touchdown celebration and he's
now become a paid endorsement an
Instagram out today of a company called
dude wipes who just I don't know exactly
what it does for you to do exact thing I
would put that I think I would put that
on my body so exact like baby wipes but
for men you know what I mean if you if
you don't know how to wipe your own butt
yeah but these are like these are like
branded for men it's like he's got not
it's like when they have like suntan
lotion for men you're like what why the
guys need this well moisturizer for men
it's like it's all the same stuff
her CBS sports this is what he said I
got the tattoo the other day there was a
lot behind it people were like are they
paying you for it and I was like no so
they were like what are you doing it for
and I was like that's who I am that's
why I am Who I am it worked out he's
supreme dear Smith so you're saying
Erica is that I was right and Greg was
wrong correct yes thank you so you would
get you would get the logo for I mean
it's a big commitment I don't I can't
think of many companies I would want to
put on there maybe you just named one
and you didn't put a lot of thought into
it even though we talked about this last
night and it was your idea to talk about
which logos we would get I had some
other ideas well your other ideas I'm
not gonna die let's go you is what is
even the logo for man wipes dude wipes
dude wipes I just like the picture of
Isaiah Crowell being so happy that they
sent him like 17 boxes of these dude
wipes you know you can't flush them down
the toilet that's the thing that's why I
don't use them Boston Celtics player
Kyrie Irving apologized on Monday for
helping to perpetuate the Flat Earth
conspiracy theory Irving well known for
buying into the idea that the earth is
flat he says that he didn't realize the
power of voice at the time I was huge
into conspiracies and everyone has been
there he said this was at the forbes
under 30 under 30 summit at the time
you're innocent but you see the power
and effect that your voice can have I
know this is a non-apology all right he
still believes the earth is flat he did
not say oh I've realized now it's round
I was dumb he says that I shouldn't have
ample
provide this and talked about it so much
and that like and that people are upset
with me because but he does think that
he's saying the right thing
it's a non-apology and everyone knows
everyone knows from from your your son
walker to neil degrasse tyson the earth
is a pyramid
[Music]
you